my British kind of like blitz okay good
news for now hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Frances Foster I'm
Constantine kissin and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with fascinating people are brilliant
returning guests this week is one of
Britain's only openly Tory comedians
Jeff norco welcome back to trigonometry
stood out still proud when you say
fascinating off with fascist
anyway this might be the last one before
society sort of like concertinas because
they're coronaviruses upstairs to the
brain why have you started with this and
then you come up with it actually
needlessly complicated one but yeah this
could be we're all in solve
self-isolation watching this this could
be the last bit you know new content
yeah it could be make people could be
watching you from the bunker this could
be it you know and then and then when
Futures societies that rebuild after the
Mad Max dystopia der coronal vice will
definitely be and we're not getting
slightly over and then this will be at
they'll judge culture by what we say in
this next hour well that's a lot of
pressure on this episode actually I was
thinking back to the last time we had
you on the show and I remember yeah just
think how much has changed it's been
less than a year my opening question I
think to you was your working-class
story what's that all about well I think
we've seen as I Spit on you with my
corona sorry that's what people normally
do anyway so just to say I love the fact
that wall hyper were we're now alive
review no we wouldn't even mention where
for mention now you like see it in slow
motion well see on the train coming down
it like those people coffin and they
look you know like in those Alien films
where where there's some sort of
contagion and one person on the ship has
got it but they're trying to hide it
yeah they've got boils coming out and
they ski
yeah now I was I was in the stage of a
day in Bromsgrove and I had a couple of
coughs come up just as you do naturally
but the stakes for for suppressing it
felt so high do you not mean I've cause
like there's the you know it's all
several thousand people in from these
are what's interesting rise if this ban
comes in and they say right Liz there's
a ban on kind of gatherings over 500
people then it will really show where
people are at in their sort of taurine
yeah cuz i go are we fine I am
comfortably yes haven't become
successful
I'm unsuccessful enough to deal with the
girl I saw you saying about like I'm
trying to make a serious point but
that's gonna out of the window with
corona but my point was my British kind
of like blitz for now is this how you
close a show Jeff that is gonna be in
tonight I just have like a little mask
on yeah I'm opening for Jeff tonight so
he's gonna be me him and three people
who still yeah I mean if the audience
are really coughing you might be doing
the whole show the outfits again in et
when the when the fellas arrived yeah
that'll be I'll come out stage on that
you know for now I'm I think what I have
is I was think about this yesterday ISM
I have certain this applies to politics
and it does apply to your point is I
have a mixture of optimism and apathy
where I I believe everything's could be
all right in the end in almost every
situation but that's also slightly borne
of the fact that I am true I'm a
pathetic enough to know I can't change
things and in this situation where you
can't change things you might as well be
optimistic yeah or if you're not going
to do anything to change things you
there's no point getting upset about
something that you're not going to
actively try and orchestrate a different
outcome so I'm gonna call it optimism
have you before about tweeting about it
though because I can make a difference
well it's we in yeah I have the
interesting thing about tweeting likes I
suppose we all come on to do the culture
wars I'm sort of thinking about why
people still feel this need to believe
that here's some sort of source like
forced
good or even change when all of the
evidence repeatedly every time the real
public get a chance to have a vote on
something suggest that it smiles out and
I was thinking one I think it's because
of me to where that was one of the few
times where I had genuinely was a
genuine the impactful movement that was
started simply on Twitter but that is
very much the exception that proves the
rule isn't it I think people have gone
well this is what could always happen
through Twitter whereas actually what
happened there was quite a useful way of
women that had you know like sexual
harassment or attacks or experiences to
come together it made sense that that
happened in Twitter where is all this
other stuff it just pisses away on the
wind you think every day there's things
that don't happen on Twitter where
people are trying to generate a movement
or a meme and you know the last election
result was a great example we all sat
there as on the day the usual thing that
was happening among the left okay you
know I think I think it could happen man
I've seen I've seen reports of like
seven people outside a polling station
in Shoreditch I think making their own
rye bread I think it could happen and
and even I even I like with my views was
off it's Jeremy gonna do it you know if
we got it if we got it and horribly
wrong and then again it may be like the
2017 election it that was another
exception that proves the rule and
Twitter is like a mask gas lighting
operation isn't it like you think that
Twitter's real life and then you have an
election you find out it really isn't
well gas lighting is a good example of a
word that is pretty much only used on
Twitter like all commies will make that
mistake we'll go out and we say hey you
just gas limey and you just feel like
this figure the room where like 97% of
people didn't know what the [ __ ] you
were talking about gas line is a Twitter
word gamin is the same genotype used
that about pee and I've used it in front
of people that would probably use that
word if they knew what it meant you know
I mean they probably find the word quite
funny gas lighting you know gamin all of
these words are kind of chattering
classes words and when I say chattering
classes I don't just mean from the left
I mean all of us that are involved in
this kind of heaving [ __ ] ongoing
culture war online that just hasn't it's
like it's like there's a country and you
don't like you find it sometimes you
hear that there's war in a country and
any people has it how did daily life go
on and then you find out the war was
only in this one bit
everything that bit is called London
London but yeah just people are off that
disposition having those debates and
that's how you end up you know with with
you know very large Tory majority all
right finally we're back to my question
about my question so I mean the irony is
that I asked you like working-class
story that's a bit weird and then what
we find out actually yeah I mean half
the country is now seemingly it seems to
be you know in the last set of polling
figures is the you know Tory vote the
expres Westminster intentions right when
they poll what would you vote there was
another election right now I think must
be evolving why the [ __ ] we have
election but in theory and it's gone up
to 50 percent and actually when you look
at like what's been happening in labour
over quite a long period of time this
actually goes back a long way this goes
back to the part of this is to do with
how they perform in England right they'd
the last time they won the popular vote
in England was I think in 2001 labour
yeah 2001 so you think that is that
that's going back to the bit when it was
good right well from their point of view
or the bit where they were propped up by
Scotland or the Welsh vote so it's been
an issue with particularly the
working-class in England for some time
but if it's any consolation to labour
they've won the moral victory every time
Jennifer oh yeah well they've
practically a one-party state since
their Queen in power they've been in
unbroken power ever since was a nine
Bevan invented the NHS which no one else
was definitely you know it's health
service that we have like it does feel
like there could be a national vote the
words do and in no Bevin just had this
Eureka moment that is odd the way that
because apparently apparently Churchill
was and you know there was a big mood at
the time of lots of people thinking how
can we have a health service that's
national and know I've ever went how
about a National Health Service servant
genius I did that Steve Jobs did with
thee you know that bill Berber it about
if we just put loads of [ __ ] on the
phone
no Bevin did that but with the Health
Service that is such a brilliant
Bilborough routine old phone can't fit
the new charger is that your hero yeah
but anyway you are you happy in terms of
do you feel like working-class people
are really having their say and they've
been heard well yeah I mean like you
know if you look at like the brexit vote
I mean they're like that that was it the
CD 2e demographic which is effectively
covers the working class and we're
swinging towards the Tories from 2015
onwards and I think it's one of those
things that people have tried to put
sticking plasters over and now I've
realized that this is a fundamental and
more long-standing migration what you
had in this last election was perhaps
some of the last bastions of people that
you would have thought would they've
never done that you know because bear in
mind you already had ex mining villages
and towns going and conservative in 2015
and 17 ashby Ben Bradley use a MP for
Mansfield you know that was an ex mine
in town so some people would just cross
in the rubicon because they just don't
feel that the Labour Party in its
current guys really represents them and
I know that that like you know a lot of
labour politicians resemble up where you
know our policies were very popular you
know but they were I think they were
saying individually engine policy was
popular economically right but did they
ever do a survey of do you want all
these done right now like even one
Parliament because I think that's a
separate thing is a manifesto is saying
this is what we going to do in the next
five years but what they were polling
was would you like some of the water
over facilities to be made public again
you know would you like you know a
rising corporation tax for the top
earners what they never said was do you
think we should do with this straight
away because it's not moving house isn't
it if you saw if you just moving house
with your mrs. or mr. right well done
mate well done way to make it work
men could date women we make a date man
I was just covering that loads of work
and then like your partner would say to
you they sometimes nipples do think up
good words yeah but but if there was say
oh we can do this we could do that and
we can knock out a kitchen and we can go
through and then we could dig up the
garden go you know what let's just not
move
sounds like a bit much and I think that
maybe the Elektra individually like
those policies but collectively for
though they were a bit much for one term
of office and also it's about realism is
it do you think all those things can be
realistically done in one budget you can
give away all that free stuff to people
that once it was double the spending
commitments of the previous manifesto
which was also seen as fairly spending
and then obviously it gets to the comedy
point where they're just going very
broadband and you go that almost sounds
like if you add like if you if you to
back socialist into a corner mm-hmm and
just like almost make them do word
association most stupid thing that'll be
it
yes got free broadband you know like a
blurted it out didn't brief a lot of
they're campaigning you know sort of her
constituencies and and you know the
parliamentary Labour Party they're just
so yeah free bullpen and it was almost
like if if you could think of a pledge
or promise that was almost self
parodying that would be in mmm free
broadband kids up woman make it free but
what do you think the challenges at this
Conservative government are going to
face near in order to because as Johnson
said they've lent him the vote yes lent
the party the vote what do they need
what do you think that's true first of
all because you've been a story you've
been a working-class story for many
years in the South I do think that there
is a difficulty ingrained opposition so
it's always is certainly great at the
firm you go up north and not Oliver
North Yorkshire a lot parts of Yorkshire
a fairly Tory and stuff so but I think
the it is really important I think the
first year is when the narrative will
get set so that's why a lot of people on
the Left to immediately trying to pin
betrayal narrative from the Tories
already because by the time the
narrative set in politics it's quite
early lot of Kolbe in his first eight
weeks he just turned up look scruffy and
read our emails he was always like you
know punching back a long way from there
so I think that they know that they have
to deliver and that's why you get them
drinking the Yorkshire tea
oh you know the old stories I do think
they'll come a point where they would
just start speaking in northern accents
as well yeah we had emergency meeting
the Corbett
and we agreed that there was trouble at
meal and we would all speak like
Geoffrey Boycott and they you know
they're both symbolic measures in terms
of having Conservative Party
headquarters up north you know and maybe
having the Lord set up north I'm happy
you put the Lord's on a permanent tour
after the England Football team when it
was a wembley stadium was getting redone
they can't exactly see if they still
want their deal yeah once they get
outside the m25 because obviously well
you know what while bricks it was an
issue the attendance right in the Lord's
went up exponentially suddenly they're
all you know wanted to exercise this
parliamentary power that they had you
know but it took breaks it for them to
do it so frankly zombie far as I'm
concerned send them to morpeth no
offense to people more than me but it
was sounds like a grimace town up north
but so I wasn't friends to the people
going back to the question what do you
think they need to do what do you think
they need to do if they're going to
retain this massive base that they've
won well I think that one of the things
is that what they've already done is
they've had a budget that was quite a
sore Blair right budget really but it's
also I mean it's already been skewed
isn't it because they had the floods
right I mean that almost seems like old
news now but that really depressed
economic activity up north and then
immediately they've had coronavirus so
what they've done is is is is taken
measures that are very much sort of
squarely focused in on people in the
most vulnerable positions so that's the
first step I think that budget the other
day was a real win a real win because
I've seen it there was a number of
levels in which it delivered not least
that when Rishi sunic got the job a lot
of people these kind of weird ironic
paradoxical racists on the left and then
say oh what they just picked any old
brown faces to snip in instead of sad
your for yeah wait ruin his big days
yeah you know you're just there cuz
you're because you're brown me badly it
turns out maybe they knew something
maybe such was given good lunch because
this is extremely talented performer you
know he was that was an exceptional
debut mmm-hmm to do a budget right after
the floods he first-ever budget and the
coronavirus and he's got to step up
there and just talk I felt a bit nervous
for
in this fight I get nose for everything
but imagine if it as I've right you have
to the nation is teetering on the brink
of economic collapse on your go son you
know it's almost like when they put an
18 year old out you're not making its
debut for a football team but yeah I
think you've got to pull one back in
extra time yeah yeah but he did a great
job but do you think are you as I don't
know what your whether your fiscally
conservative or not you're not concerned
about the fact that we just seem to be
spawning money when we owe more than
we've ever owed
well there's pragmatism as well so
that's part of the conservative sort of
I mean when it's obvious that you need
to spend money you still owe money I'm
saying we're in a slightly better
position to do that because we've got
boring down and a lot of people will be
saying at the moment you know we're
there that proves and underlines that
austerity was completely a choice but
you got me when a state happened we were
already you know did the percentage of
our or GDP that was for a structural
deficit and borrowing was massive
arguably right you could say that we
were able to spaff a bit of money now
because we did what we did and in a way
it's a good thing obviously that is
highly contested you boys do you sort of
GMB any of that way if I let me just
could be debated certainly how I see it
and I think I think yeah and I think if
in failest core been my you've never
heard that no no way you can fairness to
the the pensioner is now on his way he's
the he did he did draw the argument for
left economically but you know as a lot
of people have always said it is easier
for the right to go left economic be
that he's for the left to go right
culturally because the left are such an
utter distaste for anything that they
see to be you know right-wing thinking
or certainly in some cause patriotism
it's really difficult for them to track
badly over the way but but the right I
mean there's always are brilliantly
shape-shifting yeah the way I said he go
wow no spent some money yeah that's what
we've been saying
look we are where we are and and now is
definitely the right time to be doing
that you know in public services they
need to be invested in but it is really
easy to forget that you know in 2010
with the amount that Britain Odom was
lending there was there was there was
real potential issues of people losing
faith in our country's ability to repay
its debts we're not in that position now
and I was gonna ask why is it still I
felt like a realtor wearing the blue I
don't normally wear this is me I
normally wear like like polo shirts but
I thought you know what 40 free now do
you know what I want for lunch and my
mom who's a massive Tori and massive
she's fully right-wing first-generation
immigrant right-wing but a normal-sized
woman who normal sized woman with
massive tool reviews she looked to me
she went reaches on that Franz he's 39
years old yeah and she just stared at me
and then went and then asked me how my
comedy was doing 37 37 so why would she
came into it like yeah yes I just just
to go what my old be if I'm not Prime
Minister by the self because obviously
we're all gonna die because of computer
voice this is good time to make sort of
like pledges that you can't see through
absolutely you can bat way above your
average after the Coronas oh yeah if you
survive there's gonna be opportunities
met there absolutely is but why is it
that people are still ashamed there I
say to admit that there Tory I don't
know if they are as much now I certainly
I'd like to think though you know I've
been at the vanguard I think you know
part of he's not going to talk about in
the first place I just thought he was
sorry mature do you know I mean yeah it
was so ridiculous especially after the
2015 election we had this thing of Shia
Tories right and I thought it's so
ridiculous when you've got these two
like obviously to sort sides of a
different kind of how you manage the
world and the economy and stuff and the
idea and the idea that one of them is
inherently good and one is bad it's just
fattiest to me mmm it was embarrassing I
felt it was intellectually
embarrassing and I did feel that that
needed to be challenged you know I've
challenged her quite a lot and and I do
think now that what's harder for the
left perhaps is to East if they want to
be mean about Tory voters now it's about
set of voters that are equally
characterized as working-class so when
you kind of digging out kind of like
angry from Tunbridge Wells I'm what
about you I'm just in the closet and
like III think that you know it's it's
easier for you to just you know take the
piss out Daily Mail read here in the
southeast when you know like the Tory
may encompass a lot of people from X
mining towns again it becomes a lot
harder to pin pejoratives insults on
people is it they just got racist yeah
well no but that's leave yet more
believing but not even in like I just
think I'll leave you Tory is selfish and
evil yeah selfish evil ingredients to
Padres selfish evil person so how did
you feel you must have felt vindicated
on the day of the election you must have
been secretly about it or maybe openly
well there was a part of me I think I
didn't particularly enjoy Boris's ton of
campaigning I felt they was quite hiding
in the fridge well honey I mean like
anything the Andrew Neil interview I
just felt like but I mean obviously
strategically they clearly just didn't
appreciate was antagonist so it was such
a weak move but this but we go back to a
gaslighting right did you see the
percentage of things that the public
kind of ruefully aware of for out the
election so they listed all the big
moments the one of the biggest actually
was Jacob Riis marks insensitive
comments and Grenfell and then after
that virtually nothing so you know they
probably banked on the fact that guys
like us and you know us chattering
glasses commentary out whatever you want
to call us we were processing about this
day in day out Westbury public on given
a toss and then they'd be so good about
the degree to which the British public
care is that they're able to zero in on
what really matters right they're not
getting confused by day-in day-out PR
[ __ ] try
they are absolutely right what are the
top line issues here and if you read the
Lord Ashcroft report which I obviously
haven't I've seen it sweet I've absorbed
a very small bit of it for our chat
about that when I'm next
talking about stuff but it's really
interesting the way that it
characterizes how working-class people
saw the labor body because they're right
like there's a really smart deduction of
like well you know intentions good
they've over committed they don't really
have the competence to deliver delivery
they're distracted by social social
justice issues and niche concerns
obsessed with Palestine you know like
the public will right and sometimes
there's a real virtue in just because
because politic is so big and so
complicated there's a real merit in to
getting it right down right what are the
main issues at heart here and that's why
something like breaks it get breaks it
done with such a successful slogan
because I think I think Labor's was what
was it oh is it
it's time for real change I mean that's
very that sounds like a sort of like if
you're a pensioner that goes on a river
cruise or something like that
change your river cruise yeah but there
but all the good slogans for a while now
have been ones that are dynamic so like
whether you agree with it or not make
America great again is a dynamic
positive sentiment take back control is
a positive sentiment get brakes it done
you know for the many not the few was
quite successful the worst of recent
times was probably Hillary Clinton's was
I'm with her yes yeah who signed off on
that yeah I'm with her because the thing
is if I won it alludes to a sort of
feminist agenda which could be a good
thing right but on the another knee up
baby won't be to everybody right and
then on the other hand it makes it sound
like you're going to some sort of VIP
bar and you know even on the list
yourself you might not get in thinking
that can you know behind me you know
saying liberal bubble that stuff have to
have become clichés but they become
cliches because they're truth we've got
a fantastic new sponsor it trigonometry
which is the economist indeed the
economists are not just about economics
and finance they also cover lots of
other subjects many of you at the moment
are concerned
worried or simply interested about the
coronavirus and that is something
they've covered extensively giving lots
of interesting detail about the
potential economic impact what's going
to happen to the markets whether it
might even be a good time to invest
things like that so really recommend
checking it out
the economist is your smart guide to the
forces that are affecting the world and
changing the world around you you can
get a free copy through us all you have
to do is listen to Frances absolutely
probably the only time he's ever said
that and all you need to do is text the
word trigonometry to seven eight zero
seven zero that's text trigonometry to
seven eight zero seven zero and what
challenges do you face now as being a
conservative comedian when actually
you've won yeah I mean like I'm
definitely broadening while I'm talking
about an undercurrent or taking
liberties which is out on the road to
the end of well either humanities the
truth because I've been doing shows on
this since 2016 right certainly one in
sixteen seventeen eighteen are they're
all new hours right so so you can't keep
I mean I've seen on plain old like
bigger audiences now but you can't keep
saying the same thing creatively so I
was already talking about civil
liberties and you know like nanny state
issues which obviously Tory and Labor
guilty of and and sent you know
censorship and stuff and broader
subjects really so I didn't do that
because I thought all the toys are gonna
suddenly win this argument which solves
both like kind of like you know the sort
of magic bullet that sells bricks it and
the kind of like minority Parliament but
now I'm glad that I did because I was
already talking about different things
but I've seen the show I am I will talk
about stuff as it happens you know like
labor leadership contest there'll always
be things that come around but I think
it is interested now because it's been
so long since there was real power at
the heart of government right probably
to sort of mid early to mid Blair but
now that there is the fight is very much
about who exercises that power and
that's just as interested in any it
still involves left and right but it's
just its left and right from within you
know the body of people the executive
effectively and you know looking at the
power struggles of people like Cummings
and Johnson I spoke
another thing is as well I feel much
more easing in criticizing the Tories
now because there was a long long period
where I just felt like immediately that
wasn't coming from anywhere you know and
I felt it was totally disproportionate
whereas now you know old me I'm a
political comedian first and foremost so
my job should be to make funny jokes
about what's happening politically now
I've got a bias so that one actually
come out that will probably be more
towards the left and liberal left and
remain oh oh you know there's got to be
something about the other way because I
don't even know if you could call
yourself a satirist if there wasn't
right no there's got to be balance but
you mentioned the Labour leadership
election and I think this is maybe an
area where you talk about the culture
war being just something that people
like us engage in yeah where I think I
probably would disagree with you because
I think the Labour leadership is a good
example of where the culture war issues
that ordinary people couldn't give a
toss about have now infected major
mainstream politics to the point where
it's affecting their electoral prospects
if they keep banging on about trans
women and all this other [ __ ] you
know people don't care about that so
really it's a really good example and
that's one of the problems I mean labour
have always been incredibly proud of
their half a million membership you know
and it's an impressive stat but it also
means that they're bound to create
content right we all create content we
create content and we know sometimes the
way we need to shake that for the people
that line what we do you got fryer at
some red meat every once in a while and
that Labour have to do that for half a
million people and so what it crazes you
know they used to have 200 million
voters they've got half a million
members so they're often having to say
things and do things especially and this
is what's really killed them is how long
this leadership consensus mean they're
the only people that are delighted about
coronavirus are the Labour Party thank
God we had to fight we got to finally
stop talking in public because as you
say the best example is Lisa Nandi Bryan
who I thought it had a really good
campaign that she was give a very good
account for herself against kind of like
the big attack dog interviewers like
Andrew Neil Nick Robinson not an attack
dog but you know like a big figure
Andrew Moore but then she kind of like
she did what she did one public debate
where she she was asked about legalizing
cannabis and she said oh no oh as a war
go steady or
you know I mean steady unless a bear you
know I've had that chat and then she was
no obviously she's been asked about
trans issues where she holds a
progressive view that his way ahead of
the vast majority of the British public
he says we attention there that you're
willing to say something that's so out
on a limb and potentially a DMA in you
know or get dragged into it on one issue
in it you ask that legalizing cannabis
you're like a 1960s - well we haven't
had a chat about now I think that's a
long way often I think that that is the
problem is to win this labor leadership
election you do have to curry favor with
the membership who would like the
world's most militant patreon you know I
mean they're just demand you know
constantly demanding the things that
they give a [ __ ] about and and I think
that we're starting to see that that it
could be a hamstring for the Labour
Party because you know they're in thrall
to the unions right we've always known
that we was knew that like funding wise
Tories were big business labor would he
unions and the Lib Dems are like the
campaign for a [ __ ] relay but now
labor we've got this dual pressure which
is unions and membership and then the
unions a lot of which have this kind of
like you know 1970s stole some of them
do have a quite an old-fashioned
socialist agenda the membership have
like liberal values from the year 3000
there how could it possibly go wrong
sounds change but they still out of
power the only way to get cannabis
legalizes we need to brainwash them into
thinking that it's part of the
transition process
[Laughter]
the thing about cannabis I understand
the reticence to a point but sometimes
the British public are ahead of the
political establishment in terms of
their liberal values and yeah and I
think the concern is right and it's
always been if you're the prime minister
or leader that suggests it the first
thing you gaze the Photoshop mock-up of
you of a spliff forest is that far worse
I mean some leadership contests it
wasn't like a day that went past there
one of the men that they done smack
always became a can arms races - I've
done that weird [ __ ] where you see the
devil
Oh poo that's my dad's done heroin yeah
yeah Tory leadership is a new rock and
roll it was at that time was at that
time where as you know the Labour
leadership so yeah like like you say I
think that they keep I mean Blair is
right over money I think we all go in
this weird period of there's a lot
people say this story this story
administration could be quite Blair
right because one of the the principles
of pluralism was was don't go to war
with the public unnecessarily do not
remain like like if you really want to
do good for the country don't get bogged
down in kind of culture and identity
debates where is a lot of Labor thinking
particularly the last five years has
been the opposite now get bogged down
man don't worry about run in the country
get the nitty-gritty of things that the
membership care about and it's just it
is ridiculous to a lot of people right
you decide it you know I mean I know
that the trans women competing in sport
isn't the biggest deal when it comes to
the trans community and I know that the
vast majority of trans people over women
don't aren't competing in international
sport you know they have a high rate of
suicide there's a lot of mental health
issues there so this is the real issue
Bob seeing this one issue like with with
toilets and to a degree Spore I just
don't think you'd struggle to find
people who weren't perplexed by the idea
that someone who is still metabolically
do more metabolically demonstrable is
stronger can compete against a woman I
think I think that you you know if you
were poll if you polled on that I think
you're talking in the high 90s percents
of people I mean this is like I said I'm
guessing at this but sort of anecdotally
that's what I'd suggest so for Lisa
Nandi to not come out with a clear line
on that was an odd shell but in defense
relation Andy isn't part of the problem
which you've just alluded to is that the
Labour leadership is an impossible job
because reality is you can't please the
Socialists and you can't please the
progressives at the same time you're
gonna piss one of the either off yes
yeah and and maybe you know there was a
lot of talk for outbreak said that the
Tories wit would be the thing that would
break the talks right but they've sort
of forgot the way again that the toys
have to shape-shift an ability to just
do
form yeah as something else and where's
the Labour Party that you know I always
saw and it's isn't just being wise off
the event I always thought that it was a
bigger problem for them in the long term
because it kind of highlighted breaks it
the fault line within their pie between
the con metropolitan Liberal MP class
and then you know I've see the trade
union class on the other side but now
you've got this third element which is
the membership I mean like if Kirsten
becomes leader right and then within and
as he probably will he'll dilute the
agenda over a couple of years there'll
be a lot of labour lit members that will
want something else they want something
a bit bit spicier a bit a bit more hard
left because they've got they finally
got their chance to have that and they
won't they won't want to see it go away
so easily when it's taken from them in
in sort of late 80s they didn't have the
size of membership they didn't have the
social media now they're not just gonna
blindly vote for what they see to be as
quasi Blair right party they'll I would
suspect there'll be something that will
come up in this absence don't give
Jeremy another girl okay membership in
change UK oh yeah it would be but in
terms of the Tories I know you don't all
have a whatsapp group but do you do you
think what's always in comedy Dominic
they're all cool man and twisty a
tabloid reading deal what what tabloid
you read well I read him online now but
no you know what your rights will be up
about what in terms of you just sound
like gogglebox you read the [ __ ]
times in the card and I said okay I do
read the time talking to me always I've
stopped reading a lot of newspapers no
full stop and that's not like a
consciousness a conscious decision to
play to my working-class roots no no I
just I just I don't know why I'm totally
self-absorbed is the truth about checks
where check all my stuff ourselves and
all that
so it's not really a cool kind of like
now
I've tapped out of MSM so in terms of
the Tories I mean Boris Johnson you know
for all the people saying he'd you know
we've got a hard right government you
know he is a liberal Tory Yeah right so
do you think that he's gonna be able to
hold the Tory coalition together as more
and more people who may be kind of
economically harder right than he is or
culturally hard I mean he'd like look at
the immigration point system that
they've introduced in my opinion is
actually gonna create more immigration
not less right so do you think that he's
gonna be able to hold the Tory coalition
together effectively as a lot of the
people who were delighted that he had a
clear message on breakfast start to
realize that actually he's quite a lot
softer than many of them are well that
was odd you know watching the election
campaign in the way that he was
represented and obviously there were
those those two articles several
articles things that he said but there
were at a very least you know unwise I
mean certainly in the case of the the
warm Ellen smiles and the picking in
East LA when you read I I think it's
totally legitimate very many body to
read out go and come to the conclusion
that he's a racist but I do get the
impression at a lot of people haven't
read the article so that's what I'd say
so anyone watching this is it's really
interesting read the article because
obviously was a it was interestingly
quite an anti imperial it was a themed
piece yeah you think he was being racist
oh well but you know what I think he
does right it's because he's smart I
think he sort of takes his stance where
he knows it on the moral high ground and
then he uses that higher ground to get
in a few cheeky words that's my honest
taking it so I think he deploys that
kind of language for comedic effect or
to push the boundary because he's taking
out stunts so I don't think he's
actually as clear-cut as any of the
sides the augment what I did find was
interesting it just shows how something
can stick politically is that when I
every time I ask people if they'd read
the article they hadn't read the article
the one about Muslim women looking like
layer boxes which was done when he was
foreign secretary I think you know it's
even harder that's harder to defend
because it's just like why getting
involved in this sort of nonsense do you
not I mean like it's just I just quite
like serious politicians you know like
you know an Oracle really a long time
ago as a columnist I think it's quite
different than something written when
you were holding one of the five
great Offices of state so it's obviously
you can make a defense of it on a free
speech platform and all that sort of
stuff but like I'd rather say you know a
fair bit of my free speech stuff art is
and colonies not a [ __ ] foreign
secretary you should just be getting on
with being the foreign secretary like he
should be allowed to say it but you
don't want the four separate just total
I'm a little bit and he but he you know
that article again he was talking about
he was talking about defending the right
of women very burqa in the carbon and
his jobs in public spaces right but he's
done the same thing again he sort of
taken the morally liberal view but and I
don't know if it's him phone read me to
a certain side of what he believes to be
his supporter base so he saw that that's
what I find a bit duplicitous he
sometimes plays both of the angles you
know what I think what Corona he might
make it mandatory for women to where
they come back to my point which is can
he hold the Tory coalition together as a
liberal Tory given that you know many of
the concerns about brexit I mean there's
a significant number of people who are
seriously concerned about the level of
immigration that we've had and I'm not
sure that he's necessarily going to be
the person who is gonna you know crack
down no I don't think he will be yeah I
think you know certainly for me as a
breaks it for mine that my my desire for
the take back control of borders wasn't
to suddenly end immigration it was just
always found that having unlimited
immigration in perpetuity was a bizarre
sort of absolutism
only made forever no circumstances could
ever interfere with that right and as I
wonder if Johnson who is also you know a
liberal like me probably that was what
he took issue with more because it is
it's an example of a lack of sovereignty
is it you can't take a decision based on
your own needs but I think that what in
terms of the parliamentary party I think
that they stared the abyss in the face
so hard
like literally bits of it you know in
the fear business and their eyebrows
against vortex so they will just be
happy that the party exists the other
thing about his majority the size of it
means that there is a number of arg
types that can comfortably rebel as well
yeah
you know without without sort of causing
the downfall of the government but what
about the sorry France I just want to
get this point home what about the the
people who are working-class northern
voters perhaps whose concerns about
immigration were hard aligned than yours
right in terms of the brexit vote and
and the 2019 election do you think
there's a risk that he might alienate
them by not having a kind of more
hardline position possibly but even more
so than before there's nowhere else to
go
if you know I mean so if he alienates
them and we have another you know so
we've left the EU and the Labour Party
are still was I think what might have
been low but is after three years of
being behind in the polls they might
change leader again on they might change
tax so I can't tell what he'll be up
against by then but like I said before a
lot of things will be based on early
impressions first year or two maybe
that's why pretty Patel's you know the
noises she's been making right you made
those noises you create a narrative and
in a wicked way the left play into this
because they like you say they put the
points based system could easily create
more immigration but the left-wing press
and left-wing Twitter and social media
acts like she's the most draconian you
know anti-racist essentially her name is
brown people since its time began when
Ashley says it so that might be the kind
of thing in a way if there are more
nationalist type voters to have
gravitated towards Johnson that rhetoric
might be the thing that sort of saves it
in a weird way but Jean Alton worked
quite a dim dangerous point politically
and I'm saying that because we started
em he's now drifted further yeah this is
what you [ __ ] anyway you know how do
you 37 stopped it so I'm not going any
further I think there's no much further
right to go I mean there's no party that
there's really there anymore is there
yeah and of course the brakes party
would have argued that they weren't sort
of oriented I mean a lot of people to
argue it against that so so in the
absence of you keep yeah
there may be like going back to your
point maybe that is what what will
Johnson is politically relying on is
that electoral reality but is that not
dangerous that we do not have a credible
opposition well we make jokes about the
Labour Party yeah but it's dangerous no
but this is probably there no one ever
believes me but this is partly why I dig
out the opposition as much as I do
because I think that in the age of
spitting image right it's been in which
was a great Donald I think that means a
lot committees are hesitant about doing
anti sort of Labor Party Jones because
it's seen as by proxy being in support
of the Tories right so if you say that
on a panel shows your face on it you're
the one that would get stick and maybe
that was true in the age difference
between spitting image was was these
were puppets there was a team of rioters
people did the voices it was almost like
a Russian Roulette thing if you didn't
really know where the bullet was coming
from right so then you had a show like
spitting image which maybe thirty to
forty percent of it was about the
opposition which is what I always
thought comedies should be hmm so I so
when I'm doing the job and I know that
the people the left-wing people or lay
those will be spitting at their laptops
as I'm told I honestly think what does
he think I'm doing something of worth
because it's that and you look at a lot
of things done that I and any and then
the people that critique in the Labor
Party have said in jest have been things
if they'd listened to they would have
done better right if they would it would
have been good advice to follow so it's
not okay so just taking the piss out of
them for its own sake it's saying do you
realize how you're seen by people like
me but it's also as well right we've all
just respect the Conservatives were crap
for the past few years if you look at
the way they handle breaks it yeah awful
dreadful if you look at Windrush a
disgrace all of these things and yet we
think labor still couldn't win I love
the way he listed two things and then
all of these things should have been
enough to sink the Conservative Party it
should have been enough but one thing
that I think is odd that gets discounted
from the last few years is the jobs
market I mean like you know it's Bill
Clinton
[Laughter]
[Music]
he might die in jail yeah it's funny so
I saw a lot of things it is a really
simple joke don't write people yeah
that's the only time I've ever read with
Ches Philips on Twitter yes yeah no yeah
I think he was complaining about how he
might die in prison I should just maybe
this is why I shouldn't not vo Cosby but
bill as Bill Clinton said you know it's
the economy stupid so like the economy
is the biggest way of people having skin
in the game right where it's having jobs
having houses whatever right you all
need it to keep going so the record
number of people in employment as much
as the left try and put poet you know so
well this is because zero is contrast
one it was a beginning of the jobs
revival but after that for a long time
has been full-time jobs that have been
leading the way right people working my
waging wage settlements started to
outstrip inflation these are the irony
is is the Tories them for the first time
in a long time they were doing what
they're supposed to do right the Tory
Brandis run the economy well get people
working people feeling like they've got
a few quid actually that's been the
thing that's been discussed least about
them the last few years and what would
be sort of ironic for them is if
coronaviruses stuff derails the economy
and there seem to have handled it badly
they the jobs market is a record peak
there's only one way it could go right
so you know it could lose loads jobs
we'd still be in relatively historically
good position but it would look like
things were catastrophic and they'll
probably regret I think not making more
of that in in the good Tom's good
because weirdly the TOI spend a lot of
time trying to deal with the ways that
they're perceived negatively and turn it
around but how these things I'd do
positively they're almost got a weird
public school finger not being out and
patting themselves on the back you know
they don't seem to know how to shine a
good enough light on the buoyancy of the
jobs market so that annoncer to your
question that is the biggest single
reason I think that one of the two
biggest single reasons that the last
election result happened because when
Labour would talk about this
broken Britain and no one's got jobs and
everyone's on the food beds the truth
was for most people that wasn't true so
they're talking about you know a
political and economic environment that
didn't make sense to a lot of people
it's not saying that they weren't people
struggling of course they were but you
know people you know households had more
people in work more women in work more
ethnic minorities in work than ever
before so it was a weird narrative and
do you think is well that the left and
again I'm part of the left of the deeply
patronizing attitude to ethnic
minorities well go well they're all
gonna vote labor because they're all
liberal and that is quite frankly
bollocks well but it's also like you
know certain you know you look at you
know British Asians for quite a long
time it has it you know it's not there's
not any specific there's always been a
reasonable record of them voting for the
Conservatives and I think that
entitlement one of the things that in
size excites me most about the political
age that we're living in he's that all
of the parties are having to pitch for
the business well that's how it should
have always been
no Givens no guineas right every
election every vote well why should I
vote for you not because your granddad
worked in a mill no I mean not because
you're your granddad was a doctor and
that's what our stories do you know more
case of a play-by-play basis that's what
democracy should always mean you know
like you get party officials and so for
you a small amount that have to stay
loyal for the mechanism will work the
rest of us we're always we should always
be flunking voters really I think there
are a lot of reasons why I should I will
probably probably vote conservative but
it's not an absolute given do you saying
you can vote Lib Dem them Geoff why
probably the last elections probably Oh
beats are not vote at all because there
was like look at last election there
were times I got frustrated with the
conservative campaign but I was like I'm
not gonna vote for Lib Dems it's just
you know the arrogance of the way that
they fought her they did you know revoke
a vote and it goes me great heart that
the public were broadly in line with
rejecting that sort of extremist stance
and in labour pie I'm in just a million
miles away from a party I could vote for
so it yeah would it would have been just
to not vote at all and do you think that
we're seeing a sort of new humility
amongst our MPs
because they've sort of realized that
the game has changed there's no such
thing any
really with certain exceptions as a safe
seat and we've seen it with the way
labor got decimated so there's a lot of
people looking at their seats Incans
themselves well it's a chance I could
lose this I really need to up my game
and connect with the voter well I mean
it's no surprise that a lot of the
Labour MPs that were most sympathetic to
the idea of honoring breaks it were the
ones that face constituencies that had
voted for for brexit but they you know
around the not ignored but I mean how
labour changed policy on brexit given
the numbers and all where all their
marginals were in labour heartlands
meaning they keep making outcasts armies
to grown up in the room you know
centrist love this idea you know it's
the other in the room because he seems
clever and he is like intellectually
clever but he was one of the architects
of Labour's changing in policy on brexit
you know and he he led the way on that
and and you know their arguments that a
Labour were snookered at a election to a
point but when you know when it's
touch-and-go you look at the marginals
and all the marginals will leave
constituency I just think in in that
election because of the change in the
party membership that you've talked
about I don't think there was a way out
for them they have a disarm of that arm
and they would have ended with no arm
whatever you know you can never joined
the Labour Party again Joe you
disappointed we've got a few minutes
left you mentioned Corona and the
potential impact I mean one of the
things obviously will affect the economy
but the question is you know how much of
a discount does the government get for
the fact that it was I mean look they
can do stuff about it but ultimately
it's you know it's an act of god kind of
thing yeah yeah well it will be how it
plays out right if there is a if
eventually it Peaks in Britain in the
same one that has been doing in Italy
and if the NHS is unable to cope and if
the narrative sticks that the reason is
because of cuts and you know and stuff
like that even though there was a stat
recently has showed that the number of
hospital beds have been going down
throughout the Blair years as well but
again these things though it's whether
the narrative sticks right so they may
be held accountable for that
I mean bear in mind right if you wanted
like a historical parallel he's the you
know you know
John major 1992 surprise victory right
you know he got a huge unexpected share
of the vote immediately afterwards Black
Wednesday right Britain pulls out a year
and economies take it everything seems
to be in freefall
so this idea that like it's just a
guarantee five years of borås is it
there's a degree of economic [ __ ]
that could pull any government right any
government I mean like you look at the
the reduction in GDP that could occur
for this in in fine even the worst
elements of life fine I think like in
the credit crunch the worst in one
quarter was like minus one percent right
this could be more than that because if
people come to a pretty much a grinding
halt you can be looking at record losses
in in GDP right you could be now I'm not
being a catastrophize because of see the
way that the virus works it will also
recover quicker as well but what happens
in this period he could sort of set the
tone and is it an enviable task right I
mean enviable or never no it's not an
enviable it's not a good task for
anybody coming into this because this
simple idea of I would shut the schools
you know well shut up schools right
who's gonna stay on with them yeah yeah
it's one kid
dad dad drives a you know a coach or a
lorry to deliver food right or mum's a
doctor you know so every time you talk
about shutting stuff down you're also
taking people out of the infrastructure
of the country so at some point you know
as much as there's all these
broadcasters at the moment I mean
there's this weird thing like people
going stop listening to the chief
medical officer this is this guy on this
radio
time we started listening to the
broadcaster's cuz because these are
really tricky decisions and also there's
a decision about how you know how you
manage the degree of economic
contraction what about the effect that
that has on people in in the long run
you know so this is this isn't them this
isn't an aggregate of things this isn't
a oh you know would would well if
shutting down schools and offices and
public gatherings right now would it
slow down the spread of the virus yeah
you know if you haven't shot again for
two weeks and then reopen before the
viruses Pete it's still knocking about
so so I been surprised that the alarmism
and it's not said there's nothing to be
alarmed about but it's the scale at
which the people expect the government
to to abandon their plan which is based
on meme medical advice that they've been
given and this is the weird fig people
are tired of experts mate yeah people to
put them now weirdly I'm seeing a lot of
people who remain as who who's home you
should be listening to the experts and
now they're going [ __ ] the expo should
we listen to Piers Morgan and then put
something like me who let's be honest as
a brick city you had to ignore a certain
amount of expertise there's almost like
God to send us away to challenge our
view our own viewpoints yet again yeah
he's going right I'll show you how
subjective this all is I don't see my
view God is like a sort of appetizer
white Tory deep yeah benevolent sort of
like McMillan gods and woman make as we
keep being told yeah God isn't like
never heard this
oh it's feminists love that [ __ ] no I
don't never for well I mean I've never
spoken to be in a sort of like Evan or
my eat on my way yeah I'm seeing a male
God but like if you read asked me what I
thought God was IV gender is the first
thing because if it was the first oh you
know just wouldn't have a gender by
definition you know which so it couldn't
compete in weight lifted I'll tell you
what this is taking a turn and when the
space cake starts that was Winnie kick
Tina you just paranoid the next bit will
be us going out to get a big bottle of
sprite yeah you're getting paranoid
well actually the next bit will be our
final question yeah and the final
question is what is the one thing that
we're not talking about that we really
should be talking about as a society
well I suppose that the finger precedes
and will enter seed all of this is the
degree to which the state and people
should be telling other people to live
their lives I'm not just trying to plug
this or show again but I you to look at
the the degree of encouraged I mean you
look at schools for example right now
schools can even who you got kids not
know right even hang out cause I used to
be a teacher about Francis appearance
that he looks like he hangs around
around
and not in the teaching capacity it
would have been a case in school where
you can look in kids lunchboxes now you
know really yeah yeah they can inspect
some schools do that so so these are
this this encroachment of the state so
you know whether the toys claim that
they've reduced the size of the state or
not in so many other areas they're an
increasing body of people that feel at
liberty to tell you how you should be
living saying where you should be
driving whether you should be flying
what your kids should be eating at lunch
and and this is all happening in in in
the background and it's sort of its
above left or right politics it's beyond
breaks it or remain and and and and you
know even a pandemic right and and quite
rightly governments should take action
but the finger out when governments take
action or they pass emergency laws they
really given back again it's like
emergency taxis met vit going up to 20%
just as a temporary measure there's been
five years now you know or notes being
even longer there's 2010 wasn't it so
that's that's my concern is that we're
so used to only present organizations
and corporations knowing stuff about us
and you know like clicking they are
updated terms and conditions whatever I
mean who [ __ ] knows what we've said
to Apple just so we can keep having
music every single time we predict that
what are they saying in these things
that yeah I definitely will you donate
your your your organs while still living
to the CEO of Apple if he has like an
incurable kidney complains yeah it's
just I don't I don't want to lose my
like you to deluxe active baby edition
so yeah it's fine click-click-click so
it's not just that governments that I
could have become more interventionist
if we have all served these these these
corporations and I blame us as human
beings well we just lazily let this
stuff happen but but they're all they're
also all up in our business these are
two fascinating degree I don't think
it's I don't know if it's reversible at
this point you know because let's be
honest Amazon is [ __ ] great you've
got a terminal case of the nanny state
is what you're saying well yeah and if
you want to hear me talk about it more
you might want to come along to my plug
the talk shop where the Deaf is on tour
at the moment is deaf no calm to get
tickets yeah or if you just go
to my Twitter Facebook I mean just
difficult core taught but I know the
modern internet user needs to be told
exactly where stuff is yeah you could go
to Live Nation go to Live Nation website
and yah months or to the end of April
and yeah like despite the coronavirus
thing I had my my attendance rate last
week I you getting no shows in comedy
right was less than usual I think that
is that that's the benefit of having
part of your audience being quite brick
city I'm going more out I'll lick his
face yeah and I've been on top with Jeff
opening for him and some days it's an
absolutely brilliant Jared you'll finish
leaked that was the most random
sometimes - well like I've almost been
like okay mate yeah just like no no
that's never happened it he's always
been mildly okay can't take it when it
freaked out more than if I told him he's
lived in this country for - no it's been
it's been an absolute pleasure and like
all brexit ears Jeff needs a little bit
of Russian help every now and no but he
is a cracking show Jeff is firing on all
cylinders right now he is really really
great so make sure you go and check out
one of his shows it's got all over the
country and you're going to Adam
brothers here as well I will be taking
yeah and it'll be an amended version so
be it be fully updated so if anybody saw
me do the work in progress last year
this is going to be a completely
different show I'll be up there for
three weeks and also you do a podcast
nasan's yeah what most people think so
the revolutionary angle of what most
people think is just like what do most
people think about this trying to come
to a reasonable view on the big issues
of the day
oh well done or I may touch my elbow
thanks very much for coming on the show
they go that was the most super thing
we've ever done
we'll see you again in a week from now
with another brilliant episode take care
see you next week guys thanks for
watching guys as always subscribe to the
YouTube channel click the bell button
next to subscribe button so you get
notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media
trigger pot and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread